AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME,
WHAT'S YOUR VICE?
VICE IS AN AWARD-WINNING MEDIA
ORGANIZATION THAT DOES HARD-
HITTING STORIES ON PROVACATIVE
ART, CULTURE AND NEWS.
THEY ALSO FREQUENTLY GET THEIR
WRITERS TO PARTAKE IN BIZARRE
SOCIAL EXPERIMENTS, RESULTING IN
A WEBSITE FULL OF ATTENTION-
GRABBING HEADLINES LIKE "MY
SHORT-LIVED CAREER AS A TEENAGE
FEMALE WRESTLER" AND "GEORGE
LOPEZ GAVE ME A MAKE OVER."
COMEDIANS, I WANT YOU TO COME UP
WITH AS MANY FAKE VICE HEADLINES
AS YOU POSSIBLY CAN.
I'M GOING TO PUT 60 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK AND GO.
JESSE.
>> I LIVED IN ITALY FOR SIX
WEEKS AND NOW MY DICK PULLS
ITSELF OUT IN PUBLIC.
>> CHRIS: POINTS. ROY.
>> I WATCHED YOU SLEEP LAST
NIGHT.
>> CHRIS: POINTS. SARH.
>> I WAS A CHILD BRIDE AT 83.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
JESSE.
>> I USED TO [BLEEP] WITH
RACCOONS A LOT AND THAT'S HOW I
LOST THIS EYE.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS.
JESSE.
>> I PERFORMED A DOUBLE
MASECTOMY ON JUSTIN BIEBER AND
THEN HAD A TALL SEMEN SODOMITE
LATTE.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS.